Tonight, I'd like to
tell you about one
of the big questions in science.
It's a question that
goes back at least two
and a half thousand years,
to the ancient Greeks.
And it's a question that has
been discussed in this room
many, many times over
the past 200 years,
but it's an important question.
And I think it's important
that we revisit it.
And the question is simply this.
It's, what are we made of?
What are the fundamental
building blocks of nature
that you and me and everything
else in the universe
are constructed from?
That's the story I'd
like to tell you.
So what I'd like to do is
try and give you an overview
of our current understanding.
I'd also like to
try and give you
an overview of where we hope
to go in the future, of what
progress we can we can hope
to make in the next few years
and few decades.
And we're going to cover quite
a lot of ground in this talk.
I should warn you now,
not least because I'm
going to discuss every
single thing in the universe,
quite literally.
We're going to talk,
amongst other things,
about what's happening at the
world's most powerful particle
collider.
This is a machine that's called
the Large Hadron Collider,
or the LHC for short.
It'll come up a
lot in this talk.
And it's a machine which
is based underground
in a place called CERN which
is just outside Geneva.
We'll also talk
about experiments
in the last few years that
look backwards in time
towards the Big
Bang, that give us
some understanding
about what was happening
in the first few
fractions of a second
after time itself
started to exist.
And on top of all
this, I also want
to give you some idea about
the theoretical abstract ideas,
and even a little bit of an
idea about the mathematics that
underlies our current
understanding of the universe.
Because I'm a
theoretical physicist.
What I do is study the
equations, try to understand
the equations, that govern
the world we live in.
And so, I'd just like to
give you a flavour of what
that's about.
At some point-- I
should warn you now.
At some point, I'm even going
to show you an equation.
You know, you can get
sent on training courses
for this kind of thing.
There's a number one rule.
The number one rule is never
show them any equations.
If you show them equations,
you'll just terrify them.
At some point in
this lecture, you're
all going to be terrified,
so just prepare yourselves.
OK?
OK.
You know, there's a traditional
way to start talks like this.
The traditional way
is to be very cultured
and talk about what
Democritus and Lucretius said
two and a half thousand
years ago and the ideas
that the ancient
Greeks had about atoms.
But you know, I don't
want to start like this.
We've made a lot of progress in
two and a half thousand years,
and you know, there's
just better places
to kick off a science talk.
So the first modern
picture that we
had of what the universe is made
of, everything we're made of,
is this.
So I hope this is familiar
to most people here.
This is the periodic
table of elements.
OK?
It's one of the most iconic
images in all of science.
What we have here are
120-ish different elements.
I should point out, no
less than 10 of which
were discovered in this very
building, and which constitute,
or at least in the
1800s were thought
to constitute everything
that existed in nature.
So it's certainly true
that any material you get,
you can distill it down
into its component parts,
and you'll find that all
of those component parts
are made of one of
these 120 elements.
So it's a great
moment in science.
It's really one of the
triumphs of science.
It's also, I should add,
the reason that I stopped
doing chemistry in school.
Because if you're a chemist,
this is basically as good
as it gets.
You know, if we're honest,
it's kind of a mess.
Everything in the
universe is classified
into things on the
left that go bang
if you put them in water through
things on the right which,
really if we're honest,
don't do very much at all.
You kind of organise everything
into these stupid shapes.
And it looks a little
bit like Australia.
There's a big dip in the
top, and then there's
these two strips of
elements that you
have to put along the
bottom, because there's
no room for them in the
middle where they belong.
You know, I don't
know about you,
if I was asked to come up with
a fundamental classification
of everything in
the universe, this
isn't what I would
have gone for.
Are there any chemists
in the audience?
[LAUGHING]
I'm sorry for you.
OK.
But you know, I'm
not alone in this.
It's not just me that
thinks this is a silly way
to organise nature.
Nature itself thinks this is a
silly way to organise nature.
Of course, we know this
isn't the fundamental-- this
isn't the end of the story.
This isn't the fundamental
building blocks.
And the first person to realise
there's that there's something
deeper than this was a Cambridge
physicist called JJ Thomson.
So at the end of the
1800s, JJ Thomson
discovered a particle that
was smaller than an atom
that we now call the electron.
And in 1897, he announced
this in this room-- in fact,
in this very lecture series--
to a stunned
audience, an audience
that was so stunned
at least half of them
didn't believe
what he was saying.
There was one very
distinguished scientist
who afterwards told JJ Thomson
he thought the whole thing was
a hoax, that JJ Thomson had
just been pulling their leg.
But of course, it's not a hoax.
This isn't the fundamental
elements of nature.
And within 15 years of
JJ Thomson's discovery,
his successor in Cambridge, a
man called Ernest Rutherford,
had figured out exactly what
these atoms are made of.
And this is the picture that
Rutherford came up with.
So we now know that
each of these elements
consists of a nucleus,
which is tiny.
The metaphor that Rutherford
himself used was it's like
a fly in the centre
of the cathedral.
And then orbiting this
nucleus in, I should add,
fairly blurry orbits,
are the electrons,
which sort of fill out very
sparsely the rest of the space.
So that's a picture
of these atoms.
Subsequently, we learned
that the nucleus is not
itself fundamental.
The nucleus contains
smaller particles.
They're particles that we
call protons and neutrons.
And in the 1970s, we learned
that the protons and neutrons
aren't fundamental either.
So in the 1970s, we learned that
inside each proton and neutron
are three smaller particles
that we call quarks.
There are two different
kinds of quarks.
By the 1970s, I'm
guessing physicists
didn't have a classical
Greek education,
and had kind of run
out of classy names.
So we call these quarks the
up quark and the down quark.
OK?
For no good reason.
It's not like the up quark is
higher than the down quark.
It's not like it points up.
Just no good reason at all.
The up quark and the down quark.
So the proton consists of two
up quarks and a down quark.
And the neutron consists of two
down quarks and an up quark.
This, as far as we know, are
the fundamental building blocks
of nature.
We've never discovered anything
smaller than the electron,
and we've never discovered
anything smaller
than the quarks.
So we have three particles
of which everything we know
is made.
And it's worth stressing,
that's kind of astonishing.
You know?
We sort of take it for granted.
We learn this in school.
We don't really think
about it deeply.
Everything we see in the
world, all the diversity
in the natural world, you,
me, everything around us,
just the same three
particles with slightly
different rearrangements
repeated over and over
and over again.
It's an amazing lesson
to draw about how
the world is put together.
So that's what we have.
We have an electron
and two quarks.
And you know, these aren't the
fundamental building blocks
that the Greeks
had thought about,
and they're certainly not the
fundamental building blocks
that the Victorians
had thought about.
But you know, the spirit of the
issue really hasn't changed.
The spirit is exactly
what Democritus
said 2,500 years ago, that
they're like LEGO bricks
from which everything in
the world is constructed.
These LEGO bricks are
particles, and the particles
are the electron and two quarks.
It's a very nice picture.
It's a very comforting picture.
It's the picture we
teach kids at school.
even teach students
in undergraduate university.
And there's a problem with it.
The problem is it's a lie.
It's a white lie.
It's a white lie that
we tell our children
because we don't
want to expose them
to the difficult and horrible
truth too early on it.
It makes it easier to
learn if you believe
that these particles are
the fundamental building
blocks of the universe.
But it's simply not true.
The best theories that
we have of physics
do not have underlying them
the quark particle and the two
quark particle-- sorry, the
electron particle and the two
quark particles.
In fact, the very best
theories we have of physics
don't rely on particles at all.
The best theories
we have tell us
that the fundamental
building blocks of nature
are not particles, but
something much more
nebulous and abstract.
The fundamental building
blocks of nature
are fluid-like
substances which are
spread throughout
the entire universe
and ripple in strange
and interesting ways.
That's the fundamental
reality in which we live.
These fluid-like substances
we have a name for.
We call them fields.
So this is a picture of a field.
This isn't the kind of field
that physicists have in mind.
You know, this is what you think
a field is if you're a farmer
or if you're a normal person.
If you're a physicist, you
have a very different picture
in your mind when you
think about fields.
And I'll tell you the general
definition of a field,
and then we'll go
through some examples
so that you get
familiar with this.
The physicist's definition
of a field is the following.
It's something that, as I
said, is spread everywhere
throughout the universe.
It's something that
takes a particular value
at every point in space.
And what's more, that
value can change in time.
So a good picture
to have your mind
is fluid, which ripples and
sways throughout the universe.
Now, it's not a new idea.
It's not an idea that
we've just come up with.
It's an idea which dates
back almost 200 years.
And like so many other
things in science,
it's an idea which
originated in this very room.
Because as I'm sure
many of you are aware,
this is the home
of Michael Faraday.
And Michael Faraday initiated
this lecture series in 1825.
He gave over a hundred of these
Friday evening discourses,
and the vast majority of these
were on his own discoveries
on the experiments he did on
electricity and magnetism.
So he did many, many things
in electricity and magnetism
over many decades.
And in doing, so he
built up an intuition
for how electric and
magnetic phenomena work.
And the intuition
is what we now call
the electric and magnetic field.
So what he envisaged was
that threaded everywhere
throughout space were these
invisible objects called
the electric and
magnetic fields.
Now, we learned this in school.
Again, it's something
that we sort of take
for granted because we
learned it at an early age,
and we don't sort of appreciate
just how big of a radical step
this idea of Faraday's is.
I want to stress, it's one
of the most revolutionary
abstract ideas in the
history of science,
that these electric and
magnetic fields exist.
So let me just--
you're supposed to be
demonstrations in this.
I'm not just a
theoretical physicist.
I'm a very
It's very hard for me to do
any kind of experiment that's
going to work.
But I'm just going to show you
something that you've all seen.
They're magnets.
OK?
And we all played these
games when we were kids
or when we were in school.
You take these magnets,
and you move them together.
And as they get
closer and closer,
there's this force that
you can sort of just
feel building up that pushes,
the pressure that pushes
against these two magnets.
And it doesn't matter
how often you do it,
and it doesn't matter how many
degrees you have in physics.
It's just a little bit magical.
You know?
And you all know this.
There's something just special
about this weird feeling
that you get between magnets.
And this was Faraday's genius.
It was to appreciate that even
though you can't see anything
in between, even though no
matter how closely you look,
the space between these
magnets will seem to be empty,
he said nonetheless, there's
something real there.
There's something real and
physical, which is invisible,
but he's building
up, and that's what's
responsible for the force.
So he called them
lines of force.
We now call it the
magnetic field.
So this, of course, is a
picture of Michael Faraday.
This is a picture of
Michael Faraday lecturing
behind this very table.
Here is a drawing from one
of Michael Faraday's papers.
It was pointed
out to me earlier.
When you leave, there's
a carpet just here.
The carpet has this
pattern, this picture
just repeated on it over
and over and over again.
And on the bottom here is one
of Michael Faraday's most famous
demonstrations that he did here.
So I'll just walk you
through what Faraday did.
The thing on the right, there's
a small coil with a hand on it.
This is a battery, and the
battery passes a current
around this coil.
And in doing so,
there's a magnetic field
that's induced in this.
It's what's called a solenoid.
And then Faraday did
the following thing.
He simply moved this small
coil A through this big coil B
like this.
And something
miraculous happened.
When you do that, there's
a moving magnetic field.
Faraday's great
discovery was induction.
It gives rise to a
current in B, which
then over on this
end of the table,
makes a needle
flicker like this.
So extremely simple.
You move a magnetic
field, and it gives rise
to a current, which
makes a needle flicker
on the other side of the table.
This astounded
audiences in the 1800s.
Because you were doing something
and affecting the needle
on the other end of the
table, yet you never
touched the needle.
It was amazing.
You could make something move
without ever going near it,
without ever touching it.
We're kind of jaded these days.
You can do the same experiment.
You can pick up your cell phone.
You can press a few buttons.
You can call somebody
on the other end
of the earth within seconds.
But it's the same principle.
But this was the first
time it was demonstrated
that the field is real.
You can communicate
using the field.
You can affect things
far away using the field
without ever touching it.
So this is Michael
Faraday's legacy.
There's not just
particles in the world.
There's other objects that
are slightly more subtle that
are called fields that are
spread throughout all of space.
By the way, if you ever
want to really appreciate
the genius of Michael Faraday,
he gave this lecture in 1846.
He gave many lectures in 1846.
But there was one
in particular where
he finished 20 minutes early.
He ran out of
things to say, so he
engaged in some idle
speculation for 20 minutes.
And Faraday suggested that
these invisible, electric,
and magnetic fields
that he'd postulated
were quite literally the
only thing we've ever seen.
He suggested that
it's ripples of
the electric and magnetic field,
which is what we call light.
So it took a course 50 years for
people like Maxwell and Hertz
to confirm that this is
indeed what light is made of,
but it was Faraday's genius
that appreciated this,
that there were waves in
the electric magnetic field,
and those waves are the
light that we see around us.
OK.
So this is Faraday's legacy.
But it turns out this idea of
fields was much more important
than Faraday had realised.
And it took over
150 years for us
to appreciate the
importance of these fields.
So what happened
in these 150 years
was that there was a small
revolution in science.
In the 1920s, we realised
that the world is very,
very different from the
common sense ideas that Newton
and Galileo had handed down
to us centuries before.
So in the 1920s, people like
Heisenberg and Schrodinger
realised that on
the smallest scales,
on the microscopic scales, the
world is much more mysterious
and counter-intuitive than we
ever really imagined it could
be.
This, of course, is
the theory that we now
know as quantum mechanics.
So there's a lot I could
say about quantum mechanics.
Let me tell you one of the
punch lines of quantum mechanics
one of the punch lines is
that energy isn't continuous.
Energy in the world
is always parcelled up
into some little discrete lump.
That's actually what
the word quantum means.
Quantum means
discrete or a lump.
So the real fun starts
when you try and take
the ideas of quantum
mechanics, which
say that things
should be discrete,
and you try to combine them
with Faraday's ideas of fields,
which are very much continuous,
smooth objects, which
are waving and
oscillating in space.
So the idea of trying to combine
these two theories together
is what we call
quantum field theory.
And here's the implication
of quantum field theory.
The first implication
is what happens
for the electric
and magnetic field.
So Faraday taught us,
and Maxwell later,
that waves of the
electromagnetic field
are what we call light.
But when you apply
quantum mechanics to this,
you find that these
light waves aren't
quite as smooth and
continuous as they appeared.
So if you look closely
at light waves,
you'll find that they're
made of particles.
They're little
particles of light,
and these are particles
that we call the photon.
The magic of this idea is
that that same principle
applies to every single other
particle in the universe.
So there is spread everywhere
throughout this room something
that we call the electron field.
It's like a fluid that fills
this room and, in fact,
fills the entire universe.
And the ripples of
this electron fluid,
the ripples of the
waves of this fluid,
get tied into little
bundles of energy
by the rules of
quantum mechanics,
and those bundles of energy
are what we call the particle,
the electron.
All the electrons that are in
your body are not fundamental.
All the electrons that
exist in your body
are waves of the same
underlying field.
And we're all connected
to each other.
Just like the waves
on the ocean all
belong to the same
underlying ocean,
the electrons in your body
are ripples of the same field
as the electrons in my body.
There's more than this.
There's also in this
room two quark fields.
And the ripples of
these two quark fields
give rise to what we call the
up quark and the down quark.
And the same is true
for every other kind
of particle in the universe.
There are fields that
underlie everything.
And what we think of as
particles aren't really
particles at all, they're
waves of these fields tied up
into little bundles of energy.
This is the legacy of Faraday.
This is where Faraday's
vision of fields has taken us.
There are no particles
in the world.
The basic fundamental building
blocks of our universe
are these fluid-like
substances that we call fields.
All right.
OK.
So what I want to do in
the rest of this talk
is tell you where
that vision takes us.
I want to tell you about
what it means that we're not
made of particles.
We're made of fields.
And I want to tell you
what we can do with that,
and how we can best understand
the universe around us.
OK?
So here's the first thing.
Take a box and take
every single thing
that exists out of that box.
Take all the particles
out of the box,
all the atoms out of the box.
What you're left with
is a pure vacuum.
And this is what the
vacuum looks like.
So what you're looking at
here is a computer simulation
using our best theory
of physics of something
called the standard model,
which I'll introduced later.
But it's a computer simulation
of absolutely nothing.
This is empty space.
Literally empty space
with nothing in it.
This is the simplest
thing you could possibly
imagine in the universe.
And you can see, it's an
interesting place to be,
an empty space.
It's not dull and boring.
What you're looking at
here is that even when
the particles are taken
out, the field still exists.
The field is there.
But what's more, the field
is governed by the rules
of quantum mechanics.
And there's a principle in
quantum mechanics, which
is called the Heisenberg
Uncertainty Principle, which
says you're not
allowed to sit still.
And the field has to obey this.
So even when there's
nothing else there,
the field is constantly
bubbling and fluctuating
in what's, quite honestly,
a very complicated way.
These are things that we call
quantum vacuum fluctuations.
But this is what
nothingness looks
like from the perspective of
our current theories of physics.
It's worth saying that this
is a computer simulation.
It looks a little
bit like a cartoon,
but it's actually quite a
powerful computer simulation,
and it took a long time to do.
But these aren't
just theoretical.
These quantum fluctuations that
are there in the pure vacuum
are things that we can measure.
There's something called
the Casimir force.
The Casimir force is a force
between two metal plates
that get pushed
together basically
because there's more of
this stuff on the outside
than on the inside.
And you know, these are real.
These are things
that we can measure,
and they behave just
as we would predict
they would from our theories.
So this is nothing.
And this brings me to the more
mathematical side of the talk.
Because there's a
challenge in this.
This is the simplest
thing we can
imagine in the entire
universe, and it's complicated.
It's astonishingly complicated.
It doesn't get easier than this.
You know, if you want
to now understand
not nothing but a
single particle,
well, that's much more
complicated than this.
And if you want to understand
10 to the 23 particles
all doing something
interesting, that's
really, really much more
complicated than this.
So there's a problem in--
it's my problem, not yours--
in addressing this fundamental
description of the universe,
which is that it's just hard.
The mathematics that we use
to describe quantum fields,
to describe
everything that we're
made of in terms
of quantum fields,
is substantially more
difficult than the maths
that arises in any other
area of physics or science.
It's genuinely difficult.
I can put this in
some perspective.
There's a list of six open
problems in mathematics.
They're considered
to be the six hardest
problems in mathematics.
There used to be seven,
but some crazy Russian guy
solved one of them.
So there's six left.
You win a million
bucks if you can solve
any one of these problems.
If you know a little
bit of mathematics,
they're things like the Riemann
hypothesis, or P versus MP.
They're sort of famously
difficult problems.
This is one of
those six problems.
You win a million dollars
if you can understand this.
So what does it mean?
It doesn't mean can you
build a big computer
and just demonstrate
that these are there.
It means can you understand
from first principles
by solving the equations
the patterns that
emerge within these
quantum fluctuations?
It's an extraordinarily
difficult problem.
You know, it's writing
the kind of thing I do.
I don't know a single person
in the world who's actually
working on this problem.
That's how hard it is.
We don't really even
know how to begin
to start understanding these
kind of ideas in quantum field
theory.
OK.
This theme about the
mathematics being challenging
is something which is going to
come back later in the talk.
So I'd like just to take a
little bit of a diversion
for a few minutes and give
you a sense about what
we can do
mathematically and what
we can't do mathematically,
just to sort of tell you
what the state of play is
in terms of understanding
these theories called
quantum field theories which
underlie our universe.
So there are times
where we understand
extremely well what's going
on with quantum fields.
And that happens basically
when these fluctuations
are very calm and tame, when
they're not wild and strong.
These ones are big.
But when they're
much more calmer,
when the vacuum is much
more like a mill pond
than it is like a raging
storm, in those cases,
we really think we
understand what we're doing.
And to illustrate this, I just
want to give you this example.
So this number g is
a particular property
of the electron particle.
And I'll quickly
explain what it is.
The electron is a
particle, and it turns out
the electron spins.
It orbits rather like
the earth orbits.
And it has an axis of spin.
And you can change
the axis of that spin.
And the way you change it
is you take a magnetic field
like this.
And in the presence
of a magnetic field,
the electron will spin.
The electron will stay
in one place, but spin.
And then the axis of spin
will slowly rotate like this.
It's what's called procession.
And the speed at which the
axis of that spin processes
is dictated by this number here.
OK?
So it's not the most important
thing in the big picture.
However, historically,
this has been extremely
important in the history of
physics, because it turns out,
this is a number you can
measure very, very accurately
doing experiments.
And so this number
has sort of acted
as a testing ground for us
to see how well we understand
the theories that
underlie nature,
and in particular,
quantum field theory.
So let me tell you what
you're looking at here.
The first number is the
result of many, many decades
of painstaking experiments
measuring very, very precisely
this feature of the electron.
It's called the magnetic
moment, for what it's worth.
And the second
number is the result
of many, many decades of very
torturous calculations sitting
down with a pen and
paper and trying
to predict from first principles
from quantum field theory what
the magnetic moment of
the electrons should be.
And you can see, it's
simply spectacular.
And there's nothing
like this anywhere else
in science with an
agreement between
the theoretical calculation and
the experimental measurements.
I think it's 12 or 13
significant figures.
It's really astonishing.
Any other area of
science, you'll
be jumping up and down for
joy if you get the first two
numbers right.
Economics, not even that.
[LAUGHING]
Just that this is where
we're at in particle physics
on a good day when
we really understand
what we're doing with it.
It's substantially better than
any other area of science.
12 significant figures.
But this, of course,
I've shown you
because this is our
best result. There
are many other results that
are nowhere near as good.
And the difficulty comes
when those quantum vacuum
fluctuations start getting
wilder and stronger.
So let me give you an example.
It should be possible for
us to sit down and calculate
from first principles
the mass of the proton.
We have the equations.
Everything should be there.
We just need to work
hard and figure out
what the mass of the proton
is just by doing calculations.
We've been trying to do
this for about 40 years now.
We can get it to within an
accuracy of something like 3%.
Which isn't bad.
We're 3% there.
But we should be
much, much better.
We should be sort of pushing
these levels of accuracy.
And the reason is very simple.
We've got the right equation.
We're pretty sure we're
solving the right equation.
It's simply that we're not
smart enough to solve it.
In 40 years, the world's
most powerful computers,
lots and lots of smart people.
But we haven't managed
to figure this out.
OK.
There are other
situations that I
won't tell you about where we
don't even get off the ground.
There are some situations
where for fairly subtle reasons
we're unable to use
computers to help us,
and we simply have no
idea what we're doing.
So it's a slightly
strange situation.
We have these
theories of physics.
They're the best theories
we've ever developed,
as you can see by this.
But at the same time,
they're also the theories
that we understand
the least and it's
to make progress we sort of
have this strange balancing
act between increasing our
theoretical understanding
and figuring out how to
apply that to the experiments
that we're doing.
And again, it's a
theme I'll come back to
at the end of the lecture.
All right.
So so far, I've been talking
in a little bit of generality
about what we're made of.
And this is the punch line for
the halfway point of the talk.
You're all made
of quantum fields,
and I don't understand them.
At least I don't understand them
as well as I think I should.
So what I want to do now
is go into a little bit
more specifics.
I want to tell you exactly what
quantum fields are made of.
In fact, I'll tell you
exactly what quantum fields
exist in the universe.
And the good news
is, not many of them.
So I'll simply tell
you, all of them.
So we started with
the periodic table.
This is the new periodic table.
And it's much simpler.
You know, it's much nicer.
There are the three particles
that we're all made of.
There's the electron
and the two quarks,
the up quark and the down quark.
And as I've stressed, the
particles aren't fundamental.
What's really fundamental is
the field that underlies them.
And then it turns out
there's a fourth particle
that I've not discussed so far.
It's called the neutrino.
It's not important in
what we're are made of,
but it does play another
important role elsewhere
in the universe.
These neutrinos are everywhere.
You've never noticed them,
but since I began this talk,
something like 10
to the 14 of them
have streamed through the body
of each and every one of you,
as many coming from
above from outer space
as actually coming from
below, because they
stream all the way through
the earth and then keep going.
They're not very sociable.
They don't interact.
So this is what
everything is made of.
These are the four
particles that form
the bedrock of our universe.
Except then something
rather strange happened.
For a reason that we do
not understand at all,
nature has chosen to
take these four particles
and reproduce them twice over.
So this is actually the
list of all the fields
that make up particles
in our universe.
So what are we looking at here?
This is the electron.
It turns out there are
two other particles which
behave in every way exactly
the same as the electron,
except they're heavier.
We call them the muon which
has a mass of something
like 200 times the electron,
and the tau particle,
which is 3,000 times
heavier than the electron.
Why are they there?
We have no idea at all.
It's one of the mysteries
of the universe.
There's also two more neutrinos.
So there are three
neutrinos in total.
And the two quarks that we
first knew about are now
are joined by four others
that we call the strange quark
and the charmed quark.
And then by the
time we got here,
we really ran out of any kind
of inspiration for naming them.
We called them the bottom
quark and the top quark.
So I should stress.
We understand things very,
very well going this way.
We understand why they
come in a group of four.
We understand why they have
the properties that they do.
We don't understand it
at all going this way.
We don't know why
there's three of these
rather than two of
them or 17 of them.
That's a mystery.
But this is everything.
This is everything
in the universe.
Everything you're made of is
these three at the top there.
And it's only when you go
to more exotic situations,
like particle colliders, that we
need the others on the bottom.
But every single
thing we've ever seen
can be made out of these
12 particles, 12 fields.
These 12 fields interact
with each other,
and they interact through
four different forces.
Two of these are
extremely familiar.
They're the force of gravity and
the force of electromagnetism.
But there's also two other
forces which operate only
on small scales of a nucleus.
So there's something called
the strong nuclear force,
which holds the quarks together
inside protons and neutrons.
And there's something called
the weak nuclear force, which
is responsible for radioactive
decay and among other things,
for making the sun shine.
Again, each of these forces
is associated to a field.
So Faraday taught us about
the electromagnetic field,
but there's a field
associated to this,
which is called the gluon
field and a field associated
to this which is called
the W and Z boson field.
There's also a field
associated to gravity.
And this was really Einstein's
great insight into the world.
The field associated
to gravity turns out
to be space and time itself.
So if you've never
heard that before,
that was the world's
shortest introduction
to general relativity.
And I'm not going to say
anything else about it.
I'll just let you figure
that one out for yourself.
OK.
So this is the
universe we live in.
There are 12 fields
that give matter,
I'll call the matter field,
and four other fields
that are the forces.
And the world we live
in is these combination
of the 16 fields all interacting
together in interesting ways.
So this is what you should
think the universe is like.
It's filled with these
fields, fluid-like substances.
12 matter, four forces.
One of the matter fields
starts to oscillate and ripple.
Say the electron field
starts to wave up and down,
because there's electrons there.
That will kick off one
of the other fields.
It'll kickoff, say, the
electromagnetic field,
which, in turn, will also
oscillate and ripple.
There'll be light
which is emitted.
So that will oscillate a little.
At some point, it
will start interacting
with the quark field, which in
turn will oscillate and ripple.
And the picture we end up
with is this harmonious dance
between all these fields,
interlocking each other,
swaying, moving this
way and that way.
That's the picture that we
have of the fundamental laws
of physics.
We have a theory which
underlies all this.
It is, to put it simply,
the pinnacle of science.
It's the greatest theory
we've ever come up with.
We've given it the most
astonishingly rubbish name
you've ever heard of.
We call it the standard model.
When you hear the name
the standard model,
it sounds tedious and mundane.
It should really be replaced
by The Greatest Theory
in the History of
Human Civilisation.
OK?
That's what we're looking at.
OK.
So this is everything,
except it's not quite.
I've actually just
missed that one field.
There's one extra
thing we know about,
which became quite
famous in recent years.
It was a field that was
first suggested in the 1960s
by a Scottish physicist
called Peter Higgs.
And by the 1970s, it had become
an integral part of the way
we thought about the universe.
But for the longest
time, we didn't
have direct
experimental evidence
that this existed, where direct
experimental evidence means
we make this Higgs Field ripple
so we see a particle that's
associated to it.
And this changed.
This changed famously
four years ago at the LHC.
These are the two experiments
of the LHC that discovered it.
They're sort of the
size of cathedrals,
and just packed
full of electronics.
They're astonishing things.
This is called Atlas.
This is called CMS.
That Higgs particle
doesn't last for long.
The Higgs particle lasts about
10 to the minus 22 seconds.
So it's not like you see it and
you get to take a picture of it
and put it on Instagram.
It's a little more subtle.
So this is the data, and
this little bump here
is how we know that this
Higgs particle existed.
This is a picture of
Peter Higgs being found.
So this was the
final building block.
You know, it was important.
It was a really big deal.
And it was important
for two reasons.
The first is that this is
what's responsible for what
we call mass in the universe.
So the properties of
all the particles,
things like electric
charge and mass,
are really a statement about
how their fields interact
with other fields.
So the property that we call
electric charge of an electron
is a statement about how
the electron field interacts
with the electromagnetic field.
And the property of its
mass is the statement
about how it interacts
with the Higgs field.
So understanding this
was really needed
so that we understand
the meaning of mass
in the universe.
So it was a big deal.
The other reason that
it was a big deal
is, this was the final
piece of our jigsaws.
We had this theory that we
called the standard model.
We've had it since the 1970s.
This was the final
thing that we needed
to discover to be sure that
this theory is correct.
And the astonishing
thing is this particle
was predicted in the 1960s.
50 years we've been waiting.
We finally created it in CERN.
It behaves in exactly the
way that we thought it would.
Absolutely perfectly
behaves as we
predicted using these theories.
OK.
This is going to be the
scary part of the talk.
I've been telling you
about this theory.
And I've been waving my hands
pretending that I'm a field.
Let me tell you what
the theory really is.
Let me just show you what we do.
This is the equation for the
standard model of physics.
I don't expect you to
understand it, not least
because there are parts of
this equation that no one
on the planet understands.
But nonetheless, I
want to show it to you
for the following reason.
This equation correctly
predicts the result
of every single experiment
we've ever done in science.
Everything is contained
in this equation.
This is really the pinnacle
of the reductionist approach
to science.
It's all in here.
So I'll admit.
It's not the simplest
equation in the world.
But it's not the most
complicated either.
You can put it on a
t-shirt if you want.
In fact, if you go to
CERN, you can buy a t-shirt
with this equation on it.
Let me just give you a sense
of what we're looking at.
The first term here was
written down by Albert Einstein
and describes gravity.
What that means is
that if you could solve
this tiny little part of
the equation, just this R,
you can, for example, predict
how fast an apple falls
from a tree, or the fact
that the orbits of the planet
around the sun form ellipses.
Or you can predict what happens
when two enormous black holes
collide into each other
and form a new black hole,
sending out gravitational
waves across the universe.
Or in fact, you can predict
how the entire universe itself
expands .
All of this comes from
solving this little part
of the equation.
The next term in the
equation was written down
by James Clerk Maxwell,
and it tells you everything
about electromagnetism.
So all the experiments that
Faraday spent a lifetime doing
in this building-- in fact,
all the experiments over many
centuries, from
Coulomb to Faraday,
to Hertz to modern developments
of lasers, everything--
in this tiny little
part of the equation.
So there's some power
in these equations.
This is the equation
that governs
the strong nuclear force,
the weak nuclear force.
This is an equation
that was first
written down by a British
physicist called Paul Dirac.
It describes the matter.
It describes those 12 particles
that make up the matter.
Astonishingly,
each of them obeys
exactly the same equation.
These are the equations
of Peter Higgs.
And this is an
equation that tells you
how the matter interacts
with the Higgs particle.
So everything is in here.
It's really an
astonishing achievement
this is our current
limit of knowledge.
We've never done an experiment
that cannot be explained
by this equation.
And we've never
found a way in which
this equation stops working.
So this is the best thing
that we currently have.
OK.
It's the best thing
that we currently have.
However, we want to
do better, because we
know for sure that
there's stuff out there
that is not explained by this.
And the reason we know is
that although this explains
every single experiment we've
ever done here on Earth, if we
look out into the sky,
there's extra stuff which
is still a mystery.
So if we look out into space,
there are, for example,
invisible particles out there.
In fact, there's many
more invisible particles
than there are
visible particles.
We call them dark matter.
We can't see them, obviously,
because they're invisible.
But we can see their effects.
We can see their effects
in the way galaxies
rotate, or the way they
bend light around galaxies.
They're out there.
We don't know what they are.
There's even more
mysterious things.
There's something called
dark energy, which is
spread throughout all of space.
It's also some kind of field,
although not one we understand,
that's causing everything
in the universe
to repel everything else.
Other things.
We know that early in
the first few seconds,
earlier than that, the
first few fractions
of a second after the
Big Bang, the universe
underwent a very rapid
phase of expansion
that we call inflation.
We know it happened, but it's
not explained by that equation
that I just showed you.
So these are the kind
of things that we're
going to have to
understand if we're
going to move forward and decide
what the next laws of physics
are that go beyond
the standard model.
I could spend hours
talking about any of these.
I'm going to focus
just on the last one.
I'm going to tell you a
little bit about inflation.
So the universe is
13.8 billion years old.
And we understand
fairly well-- well,
we don't understand
at all how it started.
We don't understand what kicked
it all off at time t equals 0.
But we understand fairly well
what happened after it started.
And we know in particular
that for the first 380,000
years of the universe, it
was filled with a fireball.
And we know this for
sure because we've
seen the fireball.
In fact, we've seen it, and
we've taken a photograph of it.
This is called the cosmic
microwave background radiation,
but a much better name
for it is the Fireball
That Filled the Universe
When It Was Much Younger.
The fireball cools down.
It's light has been streaming
through the universe
for 13.8 billion years.
But we can see it.
We can take this
photograph of it.
And we can understand
very well what
was happening in these first
few moments of the universe.
And you can see, it looks
literally like a fireball.
There's red bits
that are hotter.
There's blue bits
that are colder.
And by studying this
flickering that you
can see in this picture,
we get a lot of information
about what was going on back
13.8 billion years ago when
the universe was a baby.
One of the main
questions we want to ask
is what caused the
flickering in the fireball?
And we have an answer to this.
We have an answer,
which I think is
one of the most astonishing
things in all of science.
It turns out that
although the fireball
lasted for 380,000
years, whatever
caused this flickering
could not have taken place
during the vast
majority of that time.
Whatever caused the
flickering in this fireball
actually took place in the first
few very fractions of a second
after the Big Bang.
And what it was
was the following.
So when the universe
was very, very young,
soon after the Big Bang,
there were no particles,
but there were quantum
fields, because the quantum
fields were everywhere.
And there were these
quantum vacuum fluctuations.
And what happened was the
universe expanded very,
very quickly, and it caught
these quantum fluctuations
in the act.
So the quantum
fluctuations were stretched
across the entire sky,
where they became frozen.
And it's these vacuum
fluctuations here
which are the ripples that
you see in the fireball.
So it's an astonishing story,
that the quantum vacuum
fluctuations were taking place
10 to the minus 30 seconds
after the Big Bang.
They were absolutely
microscopic.
And now we see them stretched
across the entire universe,
stretched 20 billion
lightyears across the sky.
That's what you're seeing here.
And yet, you do the
calculations for this,
and it matches perfectly
what you see here.
So this is another of the
great triumphs of quantum field
theory.
But it leaves lots of questions.
The most important one is,
which field are we seeing here?
Which field is this that's
imprinted on the background
radiation?
And the answer is we don't know.
The only one of
the standard model
fields it has a hope
of being is the Higgs.
But most of us think
it's not the Higgs,
but probably something new.
But what we'd like to do
moving forward into the future
is get a much better
picture of this fireball,
in particular get the
polarisation of the light.
And by getting a
picture of this,
we can understand much
better the properties
of this field that
was fluctuating
in the early universe.
OK.
This looking forward is
one of the best hopes
that we have for going
beyond the standard model
and understanding new physics.
In the last 10
minutes, though, I'd
like to bring you back
down to Earth, sort of.
We've got lots of
experiments here on Earth
where we're also
trying to do better,
where we're also trying to
go beyond the standard model
of physics beyond that equation
to understand what's new.
And there's many of them,
but the most prominent
is the one I've
already mentioned.
It's the LHC.
So what happened was the LHC
discovered the Higgs boson
in 2012.
And soon afterwards, it
closed down for two years.
It had an upgrade.
And last year in 2015,
the LHC turned on again
with twice the
energy that it had
when it discovered the Higgs.
And the goal was twofold.
The goal was firstly to
understand the Higgs better,
which it has done fantastically,
and secondly, to discover
new physics that lies beyond
the Higgs, new physics
beyond the standard model.
So before I tell
you what it's seen,
let me tell you some
of the ideas we've had,
some of our expectations
and hopes for what
would happen moving forward.
So this is our favourite
equation again.
The idea has always
been the following.
You know, if you were
a Victorian scientist,
and you go back, and you look at
the periodic table of elements,
then it's true that there's
patterns in there that
give a hint of the structure
that lies underneath.
Those numbers that
repeat themselves.
Where if you're very smart, you
might start to realise that,
yes, there is something deeper
than just these elements.
So our hope as theorists
is to look at this equation
and see if maybe we
can just find patterns
in this equation that suggest
there might be something
deeper that lies underneath.
And they're there.
So let me give you an example.
This is the equation
that describes the force
of electricity and magnetism.
And it's almost the same
as the equations which
describe the forces
for the strong force
and the weak nuclear force.
You can see.
I've just changed letters.
It's a little more
complicated than that,
but it's not much more
complicated than that.
The three forces
really look similar.
So you might wonder,
well, maybe there's not
three forces in the universe.
Maybe those three forces
are actually just one force.
And when we think
there's three forces,
it's because we're
looking at that one force
just from slightly
different perspectives.
Maybe.
Here's something else,
which is amazing.
These are the equations
for the 12 matter
fields in the universe-- the
neutrinos, the electrons,
and the quarks.
Each of them obeys
exactly the same equation.
the Dirac equation.
So again, you
might wonder, well,
maybe there aren't
12 different fields.
Maybe they're all the same
field and the same particle,
and the fact they look
different is, again,
maybe just because
at them from slightly
different perspectives.
Maybe.
So these ideas that
I've been suggesting
go by the name of unification.
The idea that the three forces
are actually combined into one
is what's called
grand unification.
And it's very easy.
It's very easy to write down
a mathematical theory in which
all of these are just one
force, which appears to be
three from our perspective.
There are other
possibilities here.
You might say, well
this is the matter,
and these are the forces.
And the equations are different,
but they're not that different.
Because ultimately,
they're both just fields.
So you might wonder
if maybe there's
some way in which the
matter and the forces
are related to each other.
Well, we have a theory
for that as well.
It's a theory that's
called supersymmetry.
And it's a beautiful theory.
It's very deep conceptually.
And it sort of, you know,
smells like it might be right.
Finally, you might be
really, really bold.
You might say, well, can
I just combine the lot?
Can I just get rid
of all of these terms
and just write down
one single term
from which everything
else emerges?
Gravity, the forces, the
particles, the Higgs,
everything.
I've got something for you
if you want that as well.
It's called string theory.
So we have a possibility for
a theory which contains all
of this in one simple concept.
And the question going forward,
of course, is are these right?
You know, it's very easy for us
theorists to have these ideas.
And I should say
these ideas are what's
driven theoretical physics for
30 years, but we want to know,
are they right?
And we've got a way of
telling they're right.
We do experiments.
So I should say, if you want to
know if string theory's right,
we don't have any way to
test it at the moment.
But if you want to know if some
of these other ideas are right,
then that's what the
LHC should be doing.
The reason that we built the LHC
was firstly to find the Higgs.
OK, it worked, and secondly,
to test these kind of ideas
that we've been having
to see what lies beyond.
So the LHC has been running.
It's been running for two years.
It's been running like
an absolute dream.
It's a perfect machine.
Two years.
This is what it's seen.
Absolutely nothing.
All of these fantastic
beautiful ideas that we've had,
none of them are
showing up at all.
And the question going
forward is, what are we
going to do about it?
How are we going
to make progress
in understanding the
next layer of physics
when the LHC isn't
seeing anything,
and our ideas just don't appear
to be the way that nature
works?
I should tell you, often I don't
have a good answer to this.
My impression is that
most of my community
is a little bit shell-shocked
by what happened.
There's certainly no
consensus in the community
to move forward.
But I think there's
three responses
that sort of various
people have had that I'd
like to share with you.
And I think all three
of these responses
are reasonable up to a point.
The first response to the
LHC not seeing anything
is the following.
You young kids,
you're so pessimistic.
It's all doom and
gloom with you.
You need a little
bit more patience.
You know, I didn't see
anything last year,
and I didn't see
anything this year.
But next year, it's
going to see something.
And if not next year,
it's the year after that
that it's going
to see something.
It's usually my very
illustrious senior colleagues
that have this--
and you know what?
They could easily be right.
It could easily be that
next year, the LHC discovers
something astonishing,
and it sets us
on the path to understanding
the next layer of reality.
But it's also true
that these same people
were predicting that it would
have seen something by now.
And it's also true
that this can't
keep going for much longer.
If the LHC doesn't see something
within, say, a two-year time
scale, it seems
very, very unlikely
that it's going to see
something moving forward.
It's possible.
It just seems unlikely.
So I hope with all my heart
that the LHC discover something
next year or the year after.
But I think we have to
prepare for the worst,
that maybe it won't.
OK.
Response number two.
Response number two, which is
sort of also by similar people,
well, all our theories
are so beautiful.
They absolutely
have to be correct,
and what we really need
is a bigger machine.
10 times bigger will do it.
Again, they might be right.
I don't have a good
argument against it.
The obvious rebuttal,
however, is that a new machine
cost $10 billion.
There's not too many
governments in the world
that have $10 billion to spare
for us to explore these ideas.
There's one.
The one is China.
And so if this machine is
going to be built at all,
it's going to be built by
the Chinese government.
I think the Chinese government
would see it as extremely
attractive if the whole
community of particle
physicists and engineers
that are currently
based in CERN and Geneva
move to a town that's
slightly north of Beijing.
I think they'd view that as
political and economic gain,
and there's a real
chance they may
decide to build this machine.
If they do, it's about 20
years for it to be built.
So we're waiting
slightly longer.
There's a third response.
And I should say
the third response
is kind of the camp I'm in.
I should mention upfront,
it's speculative ,
and it's probably not
endorsed by most of my peers.
So this is really just my
personal opinion at this point.
This is my take on this.
This is the equation
that we know is right.
This is sort of the bedrock
of our understanding.
But although we know
it's right, there's
an awful lot in this equation
that we haven't understood.
There's an awful lot
to me that's still
mysterious in this equation.
So although this equation
looked like there
were suggestions of
unification, maybe they're
just red herrings.
And maybe if we just
work harder in trying
to understand this
equation more,
we'll find that there are
other patterns that emerge.
So my response is, I think
that maybe we should just
go back to the drawing
board and start
to challenge some of the
assumptions and paradigms
that we've been holding
for the past 30 years.
So I feel quite
energised, actually,
by the lack of
results for the LHC.
You know?
Sort of it feels good to
me that everyone was wrong.
You know, it's when we're wrong
that we start to make progress.
So I sort of feel
quite happy about this,
and think that there's a very
real chance that we could just
start thinking about
different ideas.
I should say that there
are hints in here.
There are hints to me
about mathematical patterns
that we haven't explored.
There's hints in this
about connections
to other areas of science.
Things like condensed
matter physics,
which is the science
of how materials work,
or quantum information
science, which is the attempt
to build a quantum computer.
All these fantastic
subjects have new ideas,
which sort of feed in
to the kind of questions
that we're asking here.
So I'm quite optimistic
that moving forward,
we can make progress,
maybe not the progress
that we thought we'd make a few
years ago, but just something
new.
So that's the
punchline of my talk.
The punchline is that this is
the single greatest equation
that we've ever written down.
But I hope that someday, we
can give you something better.
Thank you for your attention.
[APPLAUSE]
There's nothing discrete about
the Schrodinger equation.
The Schrodinger
equation is something
to do with a smooth
field-like wave function.
The discreteness
is something which
emerges when you solve
the Schrodinger equation.
So it's not built into
the heart of nature.